this is the award show on country music  for you just have fun kelsea ballerini  had fun and looks stunning at the CMT  awards on wednesday in nashville she  rocked a sheer black gown that perfectly  popped against her platinum mermaid  waves it's like a really fun setting  people like where of fun things at  crazier it's just like a little looser  it's fun for us the 22 year old Peter  Pan singer is famously friends with  Taylor Swift who split from her beau  Calvin Harris last week Kelsey insists  though her girl Taylor is doing just  fine have you talked to her how's she  doing um I don't know she's incredible  she's a strong chick I'm sure she's fine  um yeah it's a bummer